it must be Friday because we're in the
park I'm Dan I'm Jess and you're joining
us for the top five stories of the
entire weeks thanks for doing that
so you know how you tends to buy a game
console or a game and then you probably
get rid of the box like I mean the
cardboard box not the actual box yeah
the shipping box it comes in yeah say
you want to keep that box or say you
didn't get that box and you only want
that box not the contest you can totally
do that for splatoon - they're selling
just the cardboard box that the game
comes in so it's like this lateen -
artwork on the outside through the
Nintendo switch edition it doesn't come
with the game it doesn't come with the
console or any of the contents it's just
if you like the box art then you can get
the box close five bucks it's currently
available for pre-order in Japan I guess
it's true if you're suddenly pendel on
anything people will buy it yeah I mean
I guess some people really like
packaging because there's also a boxed
edition all of us listening to that you
can buy which doesn't include the game
cartridge it just includes a piece of
paper with the download code but if you
want the box to put in your collection
you can do that as well so those
particular quirky box editions are only
available in Japan right now they're not
available in any other regions but an
interesting tidbit and the game itself
is out on July 21
congrat that battle 5 came out more than
three years ago now and it's still
getting new updates it is constantly the
latest was announced this week by
rockstar it's called gun running and as
the name suggests is going to involve
illegal weapons trafficking in blaine
county which is you know one of the more
suburban areas of the game you can get a
hatch is what they're calling it's
basically a storeroom where you can you
know store up your cache of illegal
weapons keep your loot essentially and
then you can sell them from there
there's actually gun ranges inside of
those locations and comes out in June
for the regular consoles ps4 Xbox one
and PC and Rockstar said we're going to
learn a lot more about the specifics in
terms of you know weapons and
customization items in the next couple
weeks so a couple of things we do know
about the vehicles that are coming with
the update there's an amphibious vehicle
on the way and the Tampa is getting a
weaponized upgrade
very cool you have an external hard
drive yes you have an xbox yes you might
be interested in the Xbox gamepad it is
a new Netflix style program for the Xbox
one that has a catalog of 100 games in
it including Halo 5 NBA 2k16 of label 3
and this week Microsoft announced that
it's coming out June first but if you
have an Xbox Live Gold subscription you
can start playing right now on a 14-day
free trial it's going to be an
ever-growing catalogue of games they
said they're going to announce and
they're going to add more games to the
platform every single month some might
drop out do do you know licensing
arrangements and things of that nature
but you can subscribe with a commitment
that there's going to be more games
every month is what Microsoft has said
on that front Xbox game pass cost $10 a
month or your regional equivalent and if
you decide to buy any game that's in the
program or any associated DLC you can
save on that as well I should just bite
in and say that my hard drives actually
feel just pictures of cats with funny
mane captions what have you done have
you done know I've been making memes
Eddie what's your middle name I do not
have one why do they keep delaying Red
Dead Redemption sir
sunrises sunsets Rockstar delays games
so rockstar announced this week that Red
Dead Redemption 2 is now coming out in
spring 2018 which is a bit of a delay
from fall 2017 just a few months coming
out PlayStation 4 Xbox one at that time
talking about the delay Rockstar said
you know it's the first game they're
developing from the ground up for ps4
and Xbox one so they need a little more
time to get it right and in an earnings
call the CEO of rocks our parent company
said it's not the result of a specific
issue just that they want to give them
more time to make sure it's going to
succeed when it does finally come out so
they said we're going to learn more
about the game in general this summer so
not too long do you really know massive
week for far cry 5 chess they've
released teaser videos box art and
finally our first look at the story
trailer so you could be playing as a
create your own character for the first
time in the Far Cry series as a junior
deputy of Polk County you're looking to
oh not overthrow but kind of rain in the
Eden's Gate cops which is taken over
your your town and Hoke County is
Montana so it's set in mainland USA and
Monday well we've seen three support
characters they are Mary Mae the
bartender who has a score to settle and
she's really good at making Molotov
cocktails she looks really cool there's
Jerome the african-american preacher but
also
throw on a shotgun also amazing and Nick
who's the pilot who's ready to go to
water saving unborn son from the cold
look it looks really interesting you'll
be able to fly planes go on bombing runs
you can throw pitch forks as throw over
weapons just like in a Far Cry primal
obviously not pitchforks in that and you
can hire dogs and you can use them to
distract enemies and also steal enemy's
weapons to bring them back to you that's
pretty cool hopefully you can't shoot
your dogs that would be awful I don't
wanna do that would be awful what's not
awful is the fact that apparently you
can play the campaign through all the
way from start to finish and co-op and
it comes out on February 27 2018 so a
little bit of a wait but not too long
that is everything we've got feed this
week do you let us know what you cared
about in that comment section and since
you're done with this video do subscribe
if you liked our episodes this week and
what else can we check out outside we
have a Friday the 13th of the game
reviewing progress that's going up right
now so check it out
awesome thank you guys so have a
wonderful weekend and we will see you
again next week
Eddie what's your favorite color blue
why don't know it's not blue it's open
damn it